don't get used to this it'll grow back
welcome to the apocalypse yeah yeah
Cubs have made it to Game seven then he
is without a beard yes oh well by the
time this goes up we'll have known if
they want or not so if Sam oh hell yeah
if not an honor to be nominated it's an
honor to make it after ago was it 80
years something like that hundred and
eight
no no uh that'd be one getting there
wasn't it like 80 something a last time
there there we were dropping atomic
bombs on Japan yeah uh so you know
happier times I'm I'm terrified beyond
the capacity for rational thought well
this is this is ghostbusters shit well
if you think that's scary let's talk
about today's real thoughts uh we don't
usually do with this close but seeing
how it's about to break a million if it
hasn't by this point in a week which for
us was pretty quick let's start out for
any versus Jason Vicki sigh I think
there's stuff to talk about there um
just I think my the one thing that I
said it and I think it holds true for
the whole movie there was there was one
moment I turned to you and I said do you
realize we are it was like 45 minutes or
more is like an hour
yeah we're an hour into this movie and
only now is Freddy actually versus Izzy
and what they did it was cool uh when
they are on screen it's fun um there's
not much of them on screen uh but when
they do it's awesome I like that part of
it absolutely wrong stream there Volker
any Jason doesn't require much but even
for that they and if you think they have
him on fire coming people death and
throwing the the naive and everything
I've kept that's pretty cool um and then
when Freddy's he's up with his
one-liners being you know silly and
stuff like that killing people uh but
he's mostly out of it until he finally
gets a power bi and finally when they
burst EJ they burst each other twice uh
it's one of those things where it's like
when they do it's really clever because
one
is in the dream world so Jason's in his
work he's gonna have the advantage and
another is in the dream world so that's
Jason to advantage ants like you said
one is in the dream world then you said
the other is in the dream work oh that's
a real world I'm sorry a real world ones
in the dream world ones in the real
world and so they each have an advantage
and it's like that's really clever
that's such a smart idea uh but
everything that's not them is so boring
and so dull stock teenage characters I
see even even by these movies these are
just such dull boring stereotypes a lot
of teens turn offense it did there's
worse teen stereotypes by me that's what
they are they're just the hey Nicholas
II WI writer yeah it just didn't look it
makes those CW shows look like hire yeah
that's all I'll say it just felt like
Dawson's Creek er what whatever show is
on now I don't watch CW them whatever
pretty white kids in trouble show yeah
unless it's a superhero in it then
somehow they make that work could you
kind of know that's the formula and they
have fun with it and stuff but with the
others well seems like yeah no no my
kids are watching like yeah this is me
not always arrow has eliciting I'm kind
of done with that no um but and the plot
just made no sense okay like it what
killed me is that bit works just like my
mother died in a car crash oh no
okay and I later it's like oh no I
killed your mother I stabbed her in bed
a hundred times I'm like then how did
you think she died in a cut like no it
wasn't even that yes it's an obvious car
crash she crashed into a knife Factory
what no no it's not even that is like
it's really Freddie
and like we don't know it's like is he
possessing him or is he like on top of
her stabbing him and then he went in to
try and kill Freddie okay oh that's
pretty complicated for the kid to see
that everything and then yet this whole
thing about that I like a little bit the
idea of all the adults doing this
conspiracy to make people forget about
Freddie at the sacrifice of like three
or four kids you know because they like
a man is greater good whatever
but I like that I like that that'd be so
twisted torment but it never seems to go
anywhere so hey they did they okay so
there's a cover-up but it does nobody
live outside of Elm Street doesn't
nobody nobody nobody looks deeper into
this it's just the whole world in a hint
that we're not supposed to pry any
further before that matter something
that I hadn't really thought about a lot
over the years but it finally was
starting to hit me when they do the
whole flash maybe was like that's right
I like kill me some little girls and
little kids and isn't that and I'm just
like you know for somebody who really
got his start killing little kids he
only seems to focus on teenager yes I'm
like famous and all the other movies but
it's like he doesn't go after kids at
once or twice he does go after kids but
you're right it's mostly teenage I I'm
just I don't I figure after how many
movies he'd finally be like you know I
need to get back to my roots cuz this is
not working feel like kids are easier to
catch I feel like guys are a little bit
more defenseless you know I should just
give Elm Street a fucking rest go to
happier hunting grounds and haunt the
dreams of some little kids I'm just like
the whole movie opens up killing little
kids I'm just like and he never kills
little kids again I I don't know maybe
something like horizon maybe deer just a
lot tear I have a feel every single
nightmare I don't know I go and I
certainly I certainly didn't see the the
remake the reboot or whatever recently i
I've seen about maybe four Nightmare on
Elm Street movies in the new nightmare
so I I know maybe they were in the
couple I missed but they seem to make up
the rules as they go and then I don't
know but I'm just like I don't know just
once again I'm just a cut so he was a
child killer that kills no children and
then there's a strange part of me that
both like highly respect but also gets a
little pissed off that they don't even
attempt to explain any of like you know
the last movie before this movie because
it was Jason axe a new nightmare which
just really go off the rails one in a
good one in one in a bad way new
nightmare was
go away I thought that was clever other
than Jason X which is so ridiculous I'm
sure it's meant to be ridiculous what
surely nightmare was even meant to be
like Canon like it's sort of its own
I think it's its own yeah I think it's
supposed to be its own thing but they do
say he's now I did the choice thing
whatever but maybe it is one of those
things where it's like you want look at
is well it's all it's still in Freddy's
world or whatever new nightmare never
happens stuff but you want Cal new
nightmare you can just be a hell they
just wrote a movie that's it you know it
is kind of what it's it's like once you
do that you can always just be an anti
rata movie it's a movie we acknowledge
just a movie even in the movie so you
know fuck it I guess um but there's a
part minute just respects they're like
we're not even gonna try but it's like I
said I don't know whether to be like
yeah kudos I get it or just be like oh
how cool with it then if they found some
way to work both stories in somehow
still um and then Jason they make out I
mean I guess I get it
but the same time I kind of figured they
were both kind of assholes hmm but it's
like no Jason's kind of the good guy cuz
I guess you can't really have sympathy
for a child place we're not a good guy
you know but yeah because the
sympathetic back I'm getting uh oh I'm
afraid of water yes the sympathetic back
yeah which I like again I want them to
be a little different that way but he's
still he'll still just randomly kill
people I mean just for really yeah but
did you see those teenagers that was a
blessing I was like some of the best
white people here you guys I've ever met
why people see Freddy and Jason is like
you know these icons of these heroes cuz
they kill off all these characters we
know they're doing us a favor
oh yeah they're weeding out the Darwin
Award winner um natural selection go
I usually really like that scene when
the water stops him and I can't remember
if water was like I mean I know he
drowns on everything but I can't
remember that was like issue was he
afraid of it in the movies I can't
remember Alan of those a new thing or
not but I like that addition and I like
I like seeing him afraid I like see him
you know resort down to a child crying
and stuff like that and I'm Freddy is
contagious
I thought that was really clever I
thought that
was kind of a cool idea I have to talk
to a horror movie aficionado I am not so
yeah if he was terrified of water I
don't I don't remember but I've seen
like two of those films so that's one of
those things like you know like how I
always always like nightmare more
because I thought at least is a little
more creative yeah I thought they were
more creative and even if they're dumb
they at least had some creativity team
and they get really dumb um but with uh
there's something to you know like
yelling Star Trek for his contact like
suddenly patrick store is this thing
about the Borg and he's obsessed and
it's like you know Ahab and the Whale
and stuff like that but it's like where
did this come from this was never in the
show really I mean after he got away I
mean he was okay I mean it never came up
again I'll air times he encountered the
Borg but I like that addition it's like
it's cool I like it i don't know they
they kind of do not like they did in
first contact well no he know right
after best now we're gonna have a
Trekkie discussion i right after best of
both worlds they did they have an
episode where he had like basically had
gone through some like PTSD like he's
recovering yeah like he's recovering
buddy the town of the borg like five or
six other times after that and it didn't
bother him this time he's like no no I'm
going to fall they've gone too far I'm
okay again I guess it's a little over
the top but they did bother him he's
like we have them but you know what I
mean like in first contact they make it
a huge deal on this big from no it is it
is a big um where and I think the same
thing with Jason where it's like even if
it wasn't as big a deal which again I'm
not sure if they added it make being a
really big deal I'm okay with it cuz I
thought was a cool idea and I like they
both sort of have their own weaknesses
you know Freddy it's just the real world
you bring him into the real world and
sure all I have are these air tank
torpedoes but you sure I'm not the dream
world um but you know the fighting when
they're fighting is great uh and it's
good action when the movie finally came
alive
yeah now there were two points it was
when Jason came out in the cornfield I'm
like okay that's a pretty awesome and
then when they finally started fucking
fighting yeah but it was like I swear to
god it was like 40 minutes until any of
that
I'm just like it was an hour until we
got our first fight sequence with them
uh it's an hour and a half movie so I
guess you could say like oh that's like
Batman V Superman which a lot of people
also didn't like um but there wasn't
that much V in it that's the problem
yeah it's per movie called vs. there's
Ben versus Batman Superman and Freddy
and Jason well you know in this point
because I was watching uh cuz I don't
know how a lot of the past versus movies
go not that there's many but stuff like
Godzilla vs. King Kong or like
Frankenstein vs Dracula the Wolfman our
May those were you know there's a couple
and I don't know if they just had to
where they fought at the end and that
was it uh you so that's stupid I mean I
understand building it up but it's
called vs. you should really have that
be the focus I mean I understand like I
said getting the background signing up
and everything but you should be what
the title of your film is um so cuz I
heard some people saying like what's it
cool that they had two fights in this
I'm like just to hear anymore it's
fuckin Jason then it better be most of
the movie at least in my opinion yeah
it's like if in Terminator 2 let's say
what's called Terminator 2 versus the
t1000 or something and they fight once
at the end I feel really ripped off I
feel like nulls give me a whole bunch of
different scenarios where they're
fighting and there are and there's
chases and there's all sorts of cool
stuff ready tag-team Jason throughout a
good chunk of it yeah sister you're an
axe I'm not sure oh sorry max but hate
and dipper sisters you know what's so
plague is Ivan I've seen him once or
twice in recent photos maybe because of
the show I just assumed he was like kind
of a scrawny kid and I doing like a
strong jaw lines up it's like I thought
he was just her like a scrawny kid you
know kind of a cracking voice is that
then you see him it's like yeah he's a
jock and I was really not expecting that
was like oh as I didn't know he was like
actually like a brute kick yo ass yeah
he's actually kind of like a football
player or something in this movie or at
least looks like one um but there's one
line he does finding the teens do fine
for what they have to do they have to be
as generic
teens and that
that's what they do there's one line
that kind of cracks me up I didn't
reference it because it was already long
enough but the when he says that he saw
her dad kill her mom he almost lives
he's like you see I
so you're dead kill your mom it feels
like a weird right kind of thing and
it's one of the things where you just
know he's watching it like I can't
believe they went with that no maybe
it's true really happened let me consult
the book it's one of the things I just
saw I was just like oh that's not the
time I shall promised and do it what the
insurance money will be great
um well make it look like a car accident
let's tell bury a body I am very glad
how few different jokes I did by the way
in this I just made a joke could it I
could have made more with the book but
no no I kept it simple um so yeah I
think this guy has also done a Bride of
Chucky which was also trying to serve
bring back you know the whole thing with
child's play and again it's kind of this
similar movie where it's like when it's
kind of funny and you see the two dolls
together and stuff it's kind of fun and
kind of so it's sofa when it's
definitely somewhere it opens with the
guy finding the Chucky doll in a storage
place that has Michael Myers mask and I
think like and I want to say Jason's
mask and like Freddy Krueger's glove or
something like that so it's very very
self-aware I think this one's a little
self-aware but not much um that deadly
bride of Jake I feel like that's a
particularly problem with horror movies
I guess it's just cuz they go on so on
you always get to that point where they
just become self-aware in it so yeah I
guess we're gonna make fun of it well
and it's weird I guess now having kind
of grown up with a seeing other movies
that just kept coming out every
Halloween like saw and Paranormal
Activity and seeing the Cata get worse
and worse it's kind of like okay I guess
I understand it you know they sort of
find something that you like and it's
like there's kind of something in each
film that's kind of neat and it'll keep
you company so memories because that
became self-aware like really quickly
yeah weird um no I
I saw the third movie
I'm not going to say it's like great or
anything but it is the best of the films
it's right on the verge like I might you
say that's a good film like it's amazing
to turn around those films well not
amazing but very impressive
um but yeah there is this self-awareness
I think almost has to come from these
horror films when they do get you know
just silly or silly or actually start
off from silly beginnings what do you
think about it Chucky is a silly
beginning Freddy Krueger is a silly
beginning Friday 13th I guess not that
silly but can very quickly become silly
um so yeah it's one of those things
where it's like there's it's not like
there's no effort you can tell like this
guy knows how to frame a shot fun he has
some fun things with depth of field he
eats obsessed with the color blue um and
you just know he has like three or four
scenes where I'm like I'm gonna make
this amazing this is gonna be in all the
trailers and everything else is okay
yeah yeah action cut fine do I've got
that he's just thinking of those three
or four scenes I was like I gotta get to
this see like I get to this is it's a
competently made film yeah and a lot
more incompetently made films but i
comfortab we made food when you're like
Oh Freddy vs. Jason I'm like oh I don't
want competence I want some awesome
awesome yeah and when I get there are
some awesome scenes that you know and
what it is awesome great why good the
rest of the movie be like that um it's
kind of like I mean we're no you know
surprise we give us away in the last one
but it's like in Ninja Turtles the out
of the shadows it's like there's some
really awesome scenes I was good the
rest of the movie be awesome yeah um so
yeah it's one of the things where it's
like I can't say I hate it
I just hate waiting to get to those
awesome scenes and see every single
boring dull non interesting thing why
not focus on what made those movies so
awesome and have those coming back not
just the checklist stuff okay we have to
have this because it's in the FEL so
just put it in let's not add anything
different let's not make it interesting
let's just put it in because it's on the
checklist so that sucks
but when they do the actual Freddy vs.
Jason the title of the film it's really
cool
so that's what you're looking for you'll
have a good ten minutes maybe at 10:15
if you're lucky but but it's it's a
solid ten it's a solid 15 minutes but
it's the only part of that movie that
was Salatin yeah but um
yeah yeah traffic I can't think it too
much else to say about it just um I'm
glad y'all wanted to see I think the
only thing about doing else like I was
the emails asking us asking like Mashhad
I'm like okay so it's either this or Van
Helsing you're both like I don't know
just do whatever you want I'm like I
think very versus Jason might get a few
more hits and it's just like do it
really great it may Raz how successful I
had already seen van Helsing too and
that movies garbage yeah I mean that
that's I'm moving along and boy first
the first ten minutes of that film are
great and then it just falls pretty much
the second van Helsing shows up in
Transylvania himself it falls apart yeah
so I might do in the future I'm not
saying I'll never do it it's just one of
those where it's like oh because it's
just so long it's so boring and again
kind of dull except for a couple scenes
so I don't know we'll probably get to at
some point but man I'm glad I was just
like eh maybe Freddy vs. Jason it's a
little shorter maybe we'll get a few
more hits so um I'm glad you guys like -
I'm glad you're sharing it around and
everything and yeah I guess that's about
it and we'll just see on the next real
fights hopefully this will be back why
go apocalypse